all right welcome to the five i think
peter ducey was trying to get a question
in there he didn't get an answer doesn't
look like all right
president biden wrapping up a speech
from the white house on his pandemic
response
biden calling it a wartime effort and
announcing new steps to boost america's
vaccine supply and
double the number of doses by the summer
that comes as the new administration is
causing some controversy after promising
to keep the battle against coven 19
free of politics president biden
criticizing the trump administration's
vaccine rollout plan saying just a few
minutes ago
the program is in worse shape than his
team expected
we've got a great team here to talk
about it jesse greg
fagan and juan um let me start with you
i have to say i have lost track of the
new administration's vaccine
program and maybe today was an attempt
by the president
to nail it down and say here's where it
is but i feel like it's been
really all over the map their plan
is order more doses because supplies are
short in many states
that's it order more doses of vaccines
that we have because
of the previous administration which
he's trying to hammer
let me just take you back to what he
said at the beginning of this
press conference he basically he
essentially said told a lie that the
vaccine program was in a state of
disarray and then
complemented the press corps in
washington uh as these
the smartest group in dc surely you
figured out so he's trying to bribe them
to life for him and cover up for the lie
here are just the statistics about
what's going on yeah
the vaccinations have been a disaster in
the blue states
but not in places like i don't know
north dakota because they started
working on their vaccine program
last summer but right now we
let last week an average of one
and a quarter million doses per day were
being administered
that is well above the 1 million mark
that joe biden and the administration
would need to reach the
100 million doses in 100 days so they're
already above that mark
last week also new cases are
falling they peaked january 8th
in the last 17 days they're down 34
because of what some doctors are calling
natural immunity
so i don't know what world he is living
in but he just told a lie and he's
trying to get the press to cover for him
that vaccine program was not in a state
of disarray before christmas we had
vaccinated more people as a nation than
any other country in the world
there is some worry that there won't be
enough for the second
dose but dr voucher said today that he
thinks that that is not going to be a
problem in the long run
juan michelle goldberg who's a liberal
columnist for the new york times wrote
today
that she thinks that biden's plan is
really unambitious and she
urged him to be bigger and bolder do you
think that's what he was doing today or
did it seem like it was kind of just the
same thing
no i think he's trying to go bigger
obviously by you know increasing the
order of the vaccine dana and i think
that
is in order you know to really meet
human need i mean obviously there are
lots of people who want the vaccine find
it at the moment difficult to get
there's lots of regulation or
different strategies for how he's trying
to impose
some order and give people reassurance
that they will be able to get the
vaccine soon i'd say that's the period
you know overall i think this is you
know not
political i i'm a little surprised
because to me
when i look at this i think to myself
gosh
don't we all want this to happen it's
pretty simple and he's trying to be
pragmatic and
yesterday there was an argument is he
saying we could all get the shot by
spring
vouching saying by late summer or fall
well here he is saying i'm not going to
increase by
50 percent the order for vaccines so
that i can assure people that
in short order they will be able to get
it but he doesn't try to say that it's
going to be magical
he says yeah we're going to have trouble
sometimes you know we may have
distribution flaws and the like things
may
you know fall through some place but i
think
i think it's just good news to have
somebody take the reins and not say oh
it's going to go away on its own
all right jesse you can comment on
anything you'd like i just wanted to
make this one point that
one of the things that the president
just talked about is the need to get
schools reopened okay
yes and schools have been given a decent
amount of money they've
added air purifiers but the teachers
unions are saying
still not good enough even if they get
vaccinated first they want the
kids to be vaccinated do you think that
the biden
administration is missing an opportunity
early on here to nip that in the bud
with the unions
i do but i'm glad joe's starting to wake
up
he wasn't hired to mess around with
women's track and
help criminal illegal aliens avoid
deportation
he was elected to tackle covid and it
looked like
president trump and operation warp speed
handed joe the ball
on the goal line and he looked like he
was fumbling it
thank god he's snapping out of that
because as an american
i want him to get shots and arms we had
operation warp speed
give out in just a matter of weeks 50
million doses to the states
and only half of them have been
administered a lot of that's on the
governors
my sources said they during these
briefings with the governors in the fall
even in the summer a lot of these guys
were just looking around not even taking
notes
they were caught flat-footed because
they bought the immediate lie
that there was no way trump and warp
speed was going to deliver on
time well now some of them are doing
well and some of them are absolutely
choking
it's a lie that there was no plan the
biden transition team had over
300 meetings with the trump
administration they knew what was going
on
i'm glad that joe's starting to shake
lose some supply
he better get on the phone with the ceos
of pfizer and moderna
because having them come this summer
that's too late
we need these tomorrow we'll pay more
american taxpayers are paying for it
we'll outbid the europeans or the
chinese for i don't care i'll pay
my parents are over 70 they're in new
york they can't get vaccinated
a lot of people can't get vaccinated i'm
glad he's invoking the defense
production act
he said he had a plan i don't know what
it is he said there were going to be
federal sites to inject people
not one federal site has been opened he
said he was going to hire federal
workers to do the injections
not one federal worker has been hired so
i'm for joe i want this to work
but he better start taking this
seriously and and cut the
the bs with these eos that no one cares
about right now
i wanted to also bring up this issue
greg um
of course talk about whatever you want
but in december alone
new york uh city lost 11 000 restaurant
jobs
so if it goes on much longer there will
be no more restaurant industry which is
one of the most important things that
makes this city function yeah
uh it's yeah i know we've been down that
road
look the problem with joe is joe can't
stop being joe
right so uh he calls this a war
effort and i think that's going to be
picked up that's like this is a wartime
effort
uh to to fight this disease who said
that first
in march 2020 who said this is our big
war
some guy named trump now there's a
there's an obvious difference between
donald trump and joe biden donald trump
is the cheerleader
right let's get this thing done it's the
primary reason why we got the vaccine so
fast
is because he said we're going to do it
and we can get it done and this is how
we're going to do it we're all going to
band together isn't this going to be
great
you can criticize that being an optimist
and and being uh
the power of persuasion wasn't enough
but then you look at biden and it's the
angel of death
it's the exact opposite and it makes you
realize
that joe really did lie a lot during the
campaign i mean he said a lot of
he said a lot of big doozies but he said
if he voted for him he'd get the
pandemic under control and now you know
he's saying uh well
there's nothing we can do to change the
pandemic in the coming months
and in fact it's going to get a lot
worse and it
you know what just so you know don't get
mad at me because it's going to get
really difficult and there's going to be
a lot of things that can go wrong
so just be patient so basically what
he's asking from america
is the kind of understanding that he uh
refused to give to trump or his
supporters
uh there's a big lie going on right now
which claims that somehow all of the
lies have stopped
no the media just stopped counting them
because their guy won
all right good talk everybody jesse we
got to blow a break so i'm going to turn
it over to you now
thank you dana joe biden's also ramming
through a progressive agenda via
executive power with no signs of
stopping
by an issuing new executive orders today
to advance
racial equity and so far he signed 17
executive orders which as you can see
wipes the floor
with his predecessors wow and that
number doesn't even include the 18
executive actions biden has also signed
the hypocrisy doesn't end there though
check out what biden said
just last year
well i got to get the votes i got to get
the votes
i have this strange notion we are a
democracy
some of my republican friends and some
of my democratic friends even
occasionally say
well if you can't get the votes by
executive order you're going to do
something
things you can't do by executive order
unless you're a dictator
we're democracy we need consensus
all right so juan let's address this
here he shattered all presidential
records for early executive action i
mean he ran
on restoring institutional norms so go
figure
why would he do this when he has the
house and the senate
i mean people in four years can just
revoke all these eos what's the deal
well i think he wants to act boldly and
aggressively out of the box take
advantage of the fact that he has
strong support growing support among the
american people at this moment jesse and
obviously
president trump used executive order and
you can be undone with another executive
order so that's what we're seeing i mean
obviously the politician
you know you know elections have
consequences as they say
but i just want to pick up on the
general theme here the general theme to
me
is can someone who is an experienced
politician like joe biden someone who's
been vice president for eight years he
was in the u.s senate for 30 plus years
can he use his power aggressively
while at the same time unifying the
country well to my mind
if you go and say aggressively i'm going
to buy more vaccine that should be
unifying because that helps republicans
and democrats if you say
you know what i want to do a better job
of expanding
uh you know the insurance marketplace so
people under the affordable care act
obamacare can get
in because those insurance marketplaces
have been closed i think that helps
republicans and democrats in need of
insurance coverage
limiting some of the barriers that were
put up on medicare
you know again this is good stuff for
republicans
and democrats mass mandates good for
republicans and democrats who care about
dealing with covet
i could go on it seems to me that if you
talk about racial justice and you know
doing a better job at
you know easing racial tension in the
country it helps republicans
and democrats this is unifying use
of his power no i would disagree
you mentioned racial equity dana i tried
to find out exactly
what this executive order did i couldn't
figure it out and
and i was wondering if if they didn't
have racial equity in the federal
government
why didn't barack obama sign an eo to
fix it
well i actually what's new about this i
would love to have a longer discussion
about this than we have time for and i i
i not mean to pass of the buck to greg
to answer this question for me but it
something happened within the last i
don't know was it
the last 18 months maybe or maybe even
shorter period than that
where the the word equality was replaced
with equity
and equality meaning um the equal
opportunity
um equity meaning you get you get
we're going to help you a little bit so
that you can get up to where these other
people
are i i find it the language change to
be
you're right confusing it but it is
going to infuse
everything that they do there and
you know joe biden has a very moderate
tone
and people have known him for a long
time um but if you thought he was going
to govern
as a moderate the actions of the last
seven days
might make you rethink that yeah
greg i'm all for racial equity equality
you name it i'm for it i tried to look
what it is though on the fact sheet
it says they want to restore racial
equity in the federal government
um i guess i'm for that but i just don't
understand why they don't explain what
that is
yeah in fact it is illegal uh
discrimination is illegal i
i know sometimes people forget that i
think it i think was a typo
in a media matters talking points memo
that was sent out to all the media it
was equality and they made a typo and
now it's equity
but actually the change is kind of um
it's kind of significant because it has
to do with outcomes and for
and and forcing everybody down to the
same outcome
that's what it means a couple years ago
dana kept saying that trump's policies
were straight down the middle
that he could do prison reform one day
then reduce immigration the other
he could cut taxes here but then
eliminate a deduction that would screw
over the rich
and she was right because his policies
were actually pretty normal
his personality however wasn't but i
didn't mind it because i just assumed
there were fewer body bags and i was
right i take a pacifist jerk
over an adorable warmonger like joe
biden
so i want i need permission uh jessie
from you to make a disgusting adolescent
immature analogy that could actually get
me into a lot of trouble but i'm gonna
do
it yeah
um greg i'm gonna take a hard pass on
that one
and i'm gonna okay no you can't would
you like to so here's the comparison
yes here's a comparison between donald
trump and joe biden they are like
different types of flatulence
trump is loud but no odor just hydrogen
and carbon dioxide
joe is silent but deadly uh a booty bomb
with 100
you know hydrogen sulfide the point
being
the the dems in the media were startled
by the sound and fury of
trump ignoring the largely benign
policies underneath the bluster
meanwhile they look at joe as the kind
old grandpa
that could probably lead us into another
war silent but deadly
well you know as as the analogy king of
the show
i don't even know what to say i am blown
away
by that analogy um let's talk keystone
pipeline
um degan what i don't understand is this
help me out you're the business expert
here
he gets rid of the keystone pipeline but
we're still going to refine
canadian oil here they're just going to
have to drive it down
or railroad it down instead of sending
it down a pipeline
that seems like that emits more carbon
does it not
it does and there are actually
government studies done about that
so they killed a pipeline that destroys
10 000
jobs it takes about a half a billion
dollars away
from indigenous people they were going
to get
indigenous suppliers and jobs half a
billion there
but we're going to create more pollution
or maybe that oil gets sent to china
it's busy building coal-fired power
plants over there
joe biden is governing for greta thunder
that's what's happening he is
destroying jobs keystone pipeline he
promised to do this remember he said
we're going to transition away from the
oil industry that was not a mistake
rejoining the paris climate accord again
bending over for china that's going to
cost every american
roughly fifteen hundred dollars in cost
oh and let's
hammer the states like new mexico that
rely on federal land for oil
and natural gas production we're going
to move away from that so
if there was prosperity in communities
from fracking
we're going to make sure that that ends
they're essentially
raising prices for every american
in energy regressive tax we're also
reducing our power on the world state so
now we may have to
buy more oil from nations that hate us
so great plan i will quote gretethonberg
how dare you